but it looks like this is home for the
night
goddamn wind
Clarence
local officials have declared a
Statewide emergency as these
unprecedented storms continue to rain
sure found a Bus full of prisoners
heading our way we got caught in the
storm we need a place to hunker down
until it's safe watch on your best
behavior while we're here let's get a
few things straight you're in my house
now I will not hesitate to shoot you if
I have to if y'all don't think this is
cruel and unusual right here
just tell me how an alligator got in
your damn police station the storm
brought him in could be infested with
them by now if you want to survive the
night we're gonna have to find a way to
get along keep an eye on him that's a
bona fide cop killer right there
we're all gonna get eaten alive
ah
foreign
[Music]